[Music]  do  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Music]  first of all thank you to timon for  submitting this theme that he wrote  i took it and used it as a base to  create this rather minimalistic piece  instead of developing it as a melody i  chose to keep it static and kept it as a  continuous motive throughout the piece  when repeating a figure such as this one  i find that it helps to use selective  gaps that give momentary breaks to the  monotony of the repetitions  [Music]  [Music]  by also creating phrases that start on  the upbeats it also adds a bit of  movement  the piece itself was mostly improvised  and i wasn't following any strict form  or chord progression i was also  responding to the delay function on the  keyboard which i was using for the first  time here  [Music]  anyway thank you so much for watching  and please share with me any ideas or  requests you have for these little  pieces subscribe if you haven't already  and i'll see you in the next video  [Music]  you